all right and we are alive hold on
do that again haha alright and we are
live again right to flashpoint back in
the building boss that's what's going on
in uh well you know got a little up I
literally go to work and I'm like Oh
exotic blips are dropping then all of a
sudden you're like dude have you seen
the news of like no I'm working it's
Wednesday what's happening you're like
oh you know twelve crazy stuffs
happening just to just drops drop it a
whole bunch of like huge discussion
topics so mm-hmm seriously so as to be
you guys may know the Destiny community
summit is probably going on literally as
we speak so they're out there in Seattle
for those who got to go hopefully you
guys are having some great discussions
can't wait to hear the feedback from
that one back will take a while for us
to hear and again they're probably gonna
be under Indies for a decent amount of
it so absolutely don't expect to have
like community people come back and be
like hey we talked about this we're
gonna see this we've got this coming in
the future
they probably have to be as hush as
bunchy at this point learning going yeah
and and as we said last week last
flashpoint you know we're really
confident with with who they who they
chose you know it from the community
their women good hands you know so I
like I like what's going on you know I
like the dialogue that we're gonna get
into based on what we saw and yeah man
it's cool is it going on right there
there are some changes happening so oh
yeah
well where do you want to kind of jump
in and start this thing or the other
province the stuff and attack man
alright so iron banner is in session
have you got a chance to dive into iron
banner six sixes yeah that felt good I
must have been ready III got a lot of
positive feedback for a lot of people I
trust actually started planning before
me
does arch it was so busy but um
yeah man I actually touched it is so
much one and I will say this the power
dropping also the power mo change where
you kill someone with that would power
ammo mmm
adds another layer to it so not only
that you got the sixes back the sixes
feels good
um you know who actually made it safe
for me to come back uh by you put a
tweet out he's like I just play what a
dorm blade got stick skills
I'm like don't leave being valuable
again sixes all right let me do it I had
so much fun man and and this is solo all
solo cute like I didn't team obviously
my clan is kind of not been claimed but
yeah it's really really been fun I've
been joined did you get a chance to play
knee as much I'm sorry I got a few
matches in on PC just as I said kind of
crazy day yesterday going on so yeah I
didn't get a chance kettle's working on
something for work so just kind of
studying up for something there so I
wanted to get a little bit more I got a
few matches in solo queueing on PC I
will say at least for me it was rough so
you had the opposite experience yeah I
was like just kind of getting rolled by
teams and that used to be the key thing
and it still is to some point with iron
banner yeah it's usually gonna be easier
with teams for sure especially
unobjective votes like control because
if you run around the corner you're like
oh I see somebody on the radar and you
turn and it's like hey there's three
you're done really go Road I mean with
sixes you'll have more people running
around but if you're not with a team and
again it's still team shouting but I
mean if you want to go trying to run
after a point you may get to the point
but then what comes around the corner to
take the point back there's more than
just one of them so there's definitely
more people running around it's a bit
crazy for me the biggest thing is when
I'm on a team randoms and then I see
like four or three or five all in the
same clan especially pop into a game
against me and you're like you know
they're talking you know they're working
their coordinator they're like are we're
gonna run here okay taking this one back
turn around it's like just the
communication is faster I have to wait
and be like alright which point has got
activity right now cuz there's not much
else I can do so I it's interesting cuz
it's like the fuse data matches that I
played you know it was real
but like I was telling you earlier
offline like the one that we did I did
lose like we got Tom I it was like that
like I said that's when I realized that
the mercy rule is working as intended
yeah I'm enjoying you know what I'm
doing the most about it though he is
that I'm finally able to break off from
my team with the old death and gays do
some solo flanking get some hero moments
you know and like I said with the mo
changes but supers being how they are
it's just been really fun man and I'm
seeing different guns that's another
thing too like I thought it was gonna be
like I mean yeah vigilant swings strong
out there but I was being in a couple
times you know I might I'm will inspire
up to him a thing I have my arm my
wisdom rebuked I'm a beast with it right
now man oh don't let me get a fuse III
I'm not even scared a curious cuz when I
see the guys with the accuracy actors I
just hop back or I'll backpedal and then
I'm just wizard baby you getting rebuke
and chastise that's gonna have some
counters but yeah I have noticed even
just what I've played and I'm just kind
of for one I'm waiting for a vigilance
wing to even drop on PC know and it's
been rough like every I'll get I'll do
milestones all the time and I can't tell
you how many duplicate pieces of armor
I've got I run a lot on my Titan and I'm
sorry do a little late look at my
inventory I literally happened again
last night I was like a couple save 40
now surely I won't there's another one
you get the Osiris's gift man it's it's
strong its strong it's now I've seen it
I mean nothing else everyone toying
around with it and just pde just as like
a kinetic pulse from range like just to
see how it goes so in time hopefully the
biggest thing that I just would like to
see at some point in this game is what
overwatch has and it's just when you
queue up as a team you're gonna get
paired against the team if there's six
people in a match and there's six people
in a match and it's two pairs of threes
it's two pairs of threes it's not
groups of people that are communicating
maybe hey we'll stick together see what
the other three do and you still have
six randoms like a little more grouping
by team I know the matchmaking could get
a little longer but hopefully with what
we've got actually coming next will help
that so no no they are bringing the when
warmind comes out there is no more
exclusive like Osiris playlist it's just
a playlist for everybody be a
competitive or casual right as you say
yep exactly that's gonna help a larger
player base yeah that's gonna help that
would be so maybe this type of larger
player base especially as all the maps
are available hopefully for whatever's
gonna come in the fall might actually
have a chance to do something like team
matchmaking we'll see
mmm but did you get a chance to play six
player Rumble um actually I did I got a
few in I liked it was okay
I mean um you know it's still certain
issues I have with it but um in
comparison to the eight that we had
before which was just absolute insanity
this is a little more control it's a
little bit how did you feel about it ah
I'm about the same I was like it doesn't
quite feel right yet so I mean the other
six weeks and stuff going on but I mean
eight was just I mean if you spawned in
and somebody had heavy it's like they
were just can't spawn camping and you
were kind of screwed so the space gives
you a little bit more room to work you
might be able to like hold down a corner
see if anybody's come and you don't play
a little more strategically but it just
still feels a little off so I know
they're working they're tweaked and so
it's gonna be a work in progress
I don't even put my finger on what it is
either I don't know I don't know in
theory like okay sixes it should be what
it is but it this way it's not the it's
not terrible but it's not the feeling of
iron banner 66 right now oh yeah I am
bad at six pieces I apologize for your
bad experience and PC butts console
peasants it's not like it literally felt
like d1 and I'm just like this is what
I'm talking about
and then another key thing I want to
mention is that on supers because the
reward is the objective is being
rewarded
yep I'm getting my supers at different
times because that was my other beef
with the old matter right remember that
there's nobody to say and here's the
other thing um if you're good enough you
can get two to three if you really
reckon sharp and capping the objectives
and you're always crazy what I'm kidding
I see you to chat but like it is real
fun like they that I am banished the
right way they still got to work on on
what you call it all Rumble yeah it's
just I can't figure why don't what it is
I don't know it's like the spawning
frequency and I wonder if it's just the
design of the maps yeah it could be
because they maybe they never intended
for that so at this point somebody at a
crucible workshop is working on hell or
high water to try and get a couple
Rumble up maps out for maybe one for
warmer and maybe more for the fall to
because they know it's like hey people
want this we got to build a couple maps
that are gonna be in the rotation that
work before this so we'll see but I mean
so far crucibles getting a little love
but I just like the fact that you know
starting mates not that far away like
three weeks I feel like a stream on the
24th way ghosts are really getting
basically yeah I'm gonna be like
watching stream and then running to work
as quick as I can because that's all I'm
gonna get to do so might cover that
stream will be afterwards but I can't
wait to see what's going on trailer to
start that stream out you think a man
they gotta start off with a trail you
know that you know the market a team is
gonna have something cinematic wise
we're gonna learn about that war mine
what is it Ana break oh it's just chicks
new anti-breakage in Chile that's kind
of the rumor running out there from
leaks and stuff like that so there's
probably gonna be another raid layer I
have no idea how they're gonna tie this
one in but yeah crap but I got a feeling
that we escaping like if there's like
what is there is do you think there's
gonna be any surprises anything that we
don't know accordant unknown play and
that's my guy um the way this expansion
is being treated is more like a comet
expansion you know I'm saying so um the
vibe I'm getting is not a smaller
content drop like if we're going to get
to the notes but like the way they're
talking it they're really revamping the
question is like you don't shout out the
king of the chat it's gonna be you know
the Ray Leia thing you know if they give
us a full raid if they somehow you know
I know it's a long shot cuz of the dev
thing my gut says they probably not so
I'm trying to temper expectation so
probably gonna be apartment duty in
right but if they were somehow to do
that and with all the other changes they
can really knock it out the park get the
good well back
everybody's feeling good we gonna have
the exotic changes that we see in that
we're gonna talk about a lot of things
that we gonna talk about say so they've
gotta change you know say but we'll see
we'll see okay cool
shout out to Curtis in my chat as well
so for everybody to in line always cool
Twitter started dropping some tidbits a
little bombs to us as so Dylan at Cosmo
and just bungee straight up drop with
little videos with regards to exotics so
previously they had previewed some of
the exotic changes coming with 1.2 so
they did the Sturm and Drang the combo
where you kill somebody with I forget
which ones the side arm you start
loading bullets that do two times damage
into the hand cannon and even two-shot
PvP it's like that that's gonna be like
that's gonna be a cool one so I'd like
to see Colonel says it is the sidearm is
drank so Sturm is probably your hand
cannon but just the idea that somebody
can to shot if you actually run around
like some some but that gives a very
high skill ceiling to open and I think
that's some of the stuff that needs to
come back everything's kind of that
whole level playing field right now but
if you're good enough then you can
actually really take advantage of some
kind of unique setup is it gonna be
worthwhile compared to other things
that's the question that still needs
answered sure at least they at least
they are addressing each weapon which is
what I'm hoping yeah in some form each
exotic weapon is getting them both
because like we've already we've already
talked about with the introduction of
master works you know and some legendary
just being so damn good
Devils yada yada like is really at this
current point there's no need you can
run all legendary loadout be fine
so to see them going in and really
trying to make these exotics exotic so
we gotta make tough decisions like you I
might need to run with you know such as
such which one do I put away you know I
mean so I do like that yep so in the
last what would you say day or two
basically I've seen these little clips
popping up on Twitter about other exotic
save changing now they mentioned
graviton Lance before so basically we
know it's the three shot pulse it's you
know it doesn't have the range drop-off
it's supposed to have that little
explosion well they felt like putting it
on steroids it seems and the thing isn't
quite a bit of fun so he goes go to the
Bungie weekly update you guys can see
all the videos they've got them up there
we won't play him in the stream but
graviton Lance if you can see the
picture there's some explosions going on
so it's a tube not burst now first and
it's got these like how would you I mean
they're almost like the Moto Romeo it
remind me of online a little reminds me
of the Warlocks lava
Slovo ball because like soon as your
hits then it disperses and it it's like
mini tracking ones that yo is beast cuz
graviton used to be true I mean it's
trash right so like just to see how much
they improve that gun that's crazy
no so we'll have to see kind of house
hang out some of these pan out and every
gun I got air gun that's just my guess I
still got to keep some things in check
but they look really cool I mean even if
it is like if you're shooting other hand
can own something you finally get that
final shot off and this head explodes
and the slope of grenades go everywhere
it's like that's really cool I can do a
couple of them together a group of
enemies or just toast and that thing has
some range on it so being able to do
that type of damage explosives from
range will be cool yeah absolutely
absolutely so we also got a glimpse of a
couple other ones as well so graviton
Lance is one another is sky burners oh
now this one is interesting whoa
now sky burners off this is
basically I don't want to call it like
so if you're not if you're 80s it still
works as a scout rifle similar long zoom
solid shot but when you're not 80s and
you're just holding it it's gonna sound
would you put your present up you know
you present no more right now at least
for me do I see yeah I'll present the
your updated WAP is not you're not
showing your Knights playing right now I
might not yeah for some reason you just
went back the I accommodate school for
my listeners they liked it there you go
better come back yet which is weird
whatever everybody yeah so prison to all
day you got wait no no not yet what's
doing it it's weird this is like it just
went back the icon I don't know it just
it now all right I'll stop and then
represent flee for whatever is it
sorry guys technical difficulties pardon
our dust yeah
fair point yeah
Coronas I know you see it on my screen
I'm streaming from mine he's just
actually I'm screaming out to him so
don't worry about oh let's try this
maybe this'll help try that so strange
how just that we back yeah keep going
anywhere buddy but I decide I'll do it
on my side keep going okay I tried to
charity and so so sky burner so how
would you describe like the shots that
are coming up they're not grenades
they're like slow pulse is slow
explosive rounds like I don't know how
you even like slugs like it's almost
acting like a mini um grenade launcher
in a way right yeah the full-auto
hormone and based on that a video later
show yep it looks really cool so this
one this will feel different which is
cool and it just gives you an option of
like hey if you're jumping up in the air
and interact you're see isn't a big
thing but this is what you've got
somebody comes up close
hey start fire these explosive slugs and
you're gonna be doing some damage in and
around them
especially if you have them so still
fairly cool
I don't know again these are well I just
want to get my after seeing like these
few previews I just want to get my hands
on everything so but yeah it looks it
looks really really good
yeah those do an exotic weapon reviews
have some stuff to talk about for a bit
yes sir
Oh how's the stream no I'm gonna share
my side just to cover it up so my guys
can a see it okay yeah keep going
so more probably one of the biggest ones
was Rat King so we had a fun little
preview here so before rat-pack
basically it would increase the rate of
fire also the damage with your bigger
groups things like that but they said
the speed that was up there people can't
pull the trigger fast enough unless
you're just like a crazy person trying
to hit as possible so it made it full
auto and if you guys watch this preview
video you're gonna laugh they melt so
they're in basically the start of the
Leviathan raid with all the majors
security for my guys there yes the huts
is like get ready get ready just unload
absolutely melt it's like there's six of
them like focus firing but mm-hmm those
are not those don't you know that is
something so and that was my always
doing with that gun cuz like that gun
has so much potential shout out to my
boy knew he's in our clan she was like
yeah we gotta get that gun we gotta do
this you know he's like I can't wait to
see what is what it'll be when all six
of us run it and we were just so
underwhelmed going first you know saying
to see them go back to this is great but
I got one request if they gonna do this
they gotta fix the UM those arms what's
those arms that if six people wear it or
something like that there's another way
on that whole yeah those are terrible
awful so annoying yeah and that's all
that's one of those duplicates I've got
like four of so it's even more just rub
it in my face cuz I don't want them
but yeah honestly these are some of the
cool things that are gonna start taking
that exotics and setting them apart and
then also we've got exotic master works
coming with this patch to both sides
coming which is honestly great
yeah and I'm dying to see how to handle
that you know I'm gonna cure as you see
because that's a very underrated thing
that's going out there you know I mean
so it's gonna be cool to see how to
handle a giant mm-hmm
so speaking of master works they haven't
mentioned really what they're gonna do
now generally we know they're gonna be
orbs and stuff like that maybe a little
bit of range a little bit but maybe the
master works for exotics are gonna be a
bit more unique because they'll ever say
I'm not gonna tease but of course he
does its course huh the master work
upgrade for Rat King is going to put a
tasty garnish on this meal you won't
want to miss out on no it's not just
your basic hey here's like 5 handling so
if this just they're just keep making
exotics better and better I am fine with
it they should be as you're saying like
all exotic should be a tough decision do
I want to run been a multi-tool or Rat
King or graviton Lance because they're
all effective just in different ways and
that's everybody's got different
playstyles so I like the fact that
they're gonna be hopefully better yeah
absolutely man
a lot of hope for that because it's
gonna be good is it's definitely
something to make us get off a legendary
masterworks as well so well that's a big
yeah it's like I don't want to miss out
on orbs just because I want to do
something different yes absolutely
so yeah exotics are looking cool we got
those options if you guys haven't seen
the videos check them out like the sky
burners oath is it's going through
normal scout rifle and then when you
start jumping up in the air and it's
just that 80s it's faster for one and
those explosive slugs man they look
pretty cool so it looks nice man look at
solid
mmm-hmm and the graviton Lance just
those explosions it's lava yeah it is
just so much stuff flying around yeah
see that at least it makes a gun feel
exotic that's kind of what I want you
want you want that power fantasy right
you want to feel like you wanted a
baddest Guardians out there you know I
mean like you don't need your
foolishness
power fantasy Segway there we go gotta
live ever listened a decimal Gary
shoutout when he's on I Jim podcast dude
is like a Segway master so it was always
great they can be cheesy but Thoreau
it's awesome yeah shout out the five
teach at low power climb this is the big
topic that caught me totally off-guard
happy about it now this may not please
everyone so you know pull the reins back
on the crazy but so last time they
wanted to talk about their adjustments
to raid rewards you know they're looking
structure better you know so it was more
rewarding things like that with the
release of the war mine they're making
changes to the size and the frequency
about grades biggest thing you guys you
know when you're leveling up in normal
destiny right now at least it was up to
you know 260 or so I don't know what it
is up to you right now for a soft cap
when you hit that soft cap you get that
pretty much anywhere public events blue
drops whatever it's fine now above that
it's gonna be a lot of harder of a grind
for multiple reasons and first the soft
cap is gonna be 340 hard cap is gonna be
380 that doesn't include mod so you know
485 but 340 is your soft cap so you got
forty levels to go through but you can
literally only get from the powerful
gear yes that's it so the idea is you're
not gonna hit it in week one yes and I
love that I love that I love that's huge
that is huge and it also stops the you
know public event farming it's off so
many issues that you would we were just
blazing to the power level cap so fast
the last you know between the first when
DLC when destiny first launched and then
the first you'll see of personal science
so easy to level like it was it was
ridiculous and this now focuses on n
level content in order to get those max
levels and that's what I've been
screaming for the longest like this is
what we're talking about
yeah I'm saying what I like I want to do
I mean it was for me and even one of my
buddies gave me a hard time because when
d2 came out I worked up to max level but
I didn't rate nearly as much as he did
he'd run the rate a few more times just
were schedules and stuff I had a chance
to join him but I was still almost the
same level by just doing basic stuff and
I'm like yeah that doesn't seem right
and like shout out to party radio they
were talking about the exact same thing
like they must have had like their ears
were burning when this thing came out
should I looked at it going we just
talked about this but seriously it's
like to me and this is kind of a debate
they were having back and forth between
a couple of those guys they had WTF game
nation on there those guys and then
k-dub they're going back and forth
saying hey the casual player still
eventually needs to be able to get to
you know this thing and it was it was a
good argument to had won back and forth
and I wanted to reiterate it so some
people spent 30 40 tribes trying to get
this DFA handcannon last week right and
it's a hard thing to get to now one of
me okay Desmond thought was hey you
could potentially set up to where you
know if you don't get it you get a 10%
higher chance every time so somebody
could be like well if I run it ten times
then I know I get it right that still
doesn't give you hey after 30 times and
it finally drops that exactly did you
know when you history it is a like this
is what got us in the problem right now
and again this is no disrespect to the
casual base we want casuals to play but
we there has to be a separator there has
to be something that makes another
Guardian that significant better by
showing the amount of work that he's put
in you know I mean that that's the thing
that you strive for you like damn I want
to I want to get those boots I want to
get that special gun that this guy got
how many times and orangy part of that
was defined like you remember those
moments when that galley first dropped
me like yes you know I mean it was hard
yes some of it is luck no doubt but a
lot of it is rewarded by dedication to
in game and higher content all this
percentages and helping this guy you
know more and all that that's what got
us in this problem when everyone get
everything and they're done yeah I mean
that's where everybody is that right now
there's no point I mean you look you log
in you look at your milestones you're
like okay I might accidentally if you do
a few of those but I mean there's still
no point if we're sitting at Mack so
it'll be like powerful gear oh here's
another thing I'll breakdown or another
duplicate exotic at this point is all
I'm seeing when I do those milestones so
no for me this is really really exciting
because yeah tickets
I mean level like forever 29 in destiny
one in vanilla
it was rough it was rough but it for
sure gave me a reason to log in exactly
like why would you why would you log in
if you were already max level why would
you have an incentive to go try more
difficult content like the raid if it
doesn't benefit you at all yes
absolutely absolutely love the [ __ ] I
did I would be really bad as I did not
think they would do it no I wasn't think
cuz we talked about the country but I
remember we talked before like you know
I think we even I think I may have
tweeted CJ CJ berry or whatever and said
like hey like wise Bungie mom on power
not mattering why can't we get any
comment on that and it was interesting
the way out the back then the vibe a guy
was like you know what they're digging
their heels in they're not gonna change
it they want to you know appease to the
casual base and this is just what it's
gonna be so I'll be honest like after a
couple of months of me screaming to the
heavens I gotta give afford it so to see
this comeback kind of out of nowhere
right like this just came to me this is
huge I think this is a big deal this is
a huge step in the right direction in my
opinion this is one of my number one
cross even more so then weapon placement
I know a lot about the doc in Asia
shout out to all the community that
wants the weapon slot changes I get that
I want that too
but to me a power doesn't matter what's
the point exactly
and I'm with you it's like mm-hmm that's
exactly what we're going for cuz if I
run through and you know I knock out
everything I mean I came from World of
Warcraft and believe me you or dot max
you were not top tier by any stretch of
the imagination
just like in dusty they may take the
regular power level and when you finish
the campaign it may bump up to 30
who knows that's a guess they did five
last time for the campaign that level
doesn't matter
it's your gear in every gear if you can
get up to 340 you can run around in the
world you can do any basic nightfall you
can do strikes you can do other stuff if
you want to but if you want to start
stepping into the end game you want to
step into a prestige anything you gotta
work for it and that's it and that I
like absolutely you should have to you
got to put in the work if you want to if
you want casual be like hey I want to
jump into crucible don't be healed or
doesn't matter there do some public
events your rate is a time commitment
you should be rewarded but for putting
in that time and I think that was the
thing - those are the rate take some
time to learn take some time to go
through people have a fairly mastered
now but it just didn't have the
incentive when I could turn around and
go far in public events and get the same
level stuff so now you see that in that
paragraph when they'd explained it and
he's just like you know as far as - I'll
be up to that party graph wouldn't you
know our targets that four players will
participate in all that weekend
activities yes it takes several weeks to
reach the hard cat raids and trials
grant the larger increases clan engrams
provide small increases or thrown off a
cliff between those two players who
don't participate in any group weekly
activities are unlikely to hit the hard
cap before the next race thank God if
you're not playing and you not grind and
you not you should not get it that you
should not be rising on in level that
fast
I completely agree this is this is music
music to my ears love this change love
it yeah and then if I break it down even
more so they're saying the time it takes
to go from so your soft cap is gonna be
340 that's where basically most random
drops public events those things are
gonna stop being helpful your powerful
gear will start to help there they said
the bigger group jumps from radom trials
those are gonna be the bigger bumps but
they might be like 10 level something
like that but that's say one or two
pieces you're not gonna get it all so as
you go through that they said even so
342 370 is
going to be about the same amount of
time it takes to go from 370 to 380 so I
really slow it down to the end and
that's your final tier stuff and again
the final piece is probably the radio
and a couple more if you got three
characters I mean yeah you might get
some more weapons but that armor it's
gonna be a grind it's gonna be some work
you know and ultimately this benefits
them right this dis benefits Bungie by
getting us to play the endgame content
more that's a requirement you know and
that not today so this is all good man
this is really really good that three
especially like that 370 to 380 kinda
grind again like that's gonna be fun
like you got a dedicate you're gonna
have to go to those high-end content
power sources to get those kind of drops
to get those increases and that's the
way it's always been and that's the way
it should be yeah I'm with you there
so II haven't chat actually had a
question he's like I like this but I
hope they don't make the rain and trails
the only way to reach 380 no not trying
to piss off anybody in my chat but what
do you think so I mean that's that final
tier so what are your three the only way
to get there is 380 do you think that is
like too much of like a separation or
that's where it should be that's where
it should be the raid is the highest in
content in destiny that's the high end
content you need to no disrespect to our
listeners but you need to play it you
need to attempt it you know I'm saying
that was what incentivize people who
never played when they were playing
taken King came out people like hey man
I got to get my light up to whatever it
was a time 335 whatever it was and it's
like hey man and even when they didn't
finish it at least when they got to a
checkpoint they got two drops remember
and it was just like those trucks I
really helped my light out you know that
kind of thing and that incentivize you
to keep playing that's part of destiny
coach this is not new again if we get
into this oh do I also I have to play
you know the end content kind of stuff
that like people that don't want to play
it we're gonna be back to where we are
now which is every source gives it to
you you get everything and you're done
with destiny we don't want to be done
with this no and it's a tough line to
walk because
there are both sides of the spectrum
it's like I understand that but does we
have question and chat and I'll let you
give you some time to answer for any of
you guys out there that are on the more
hey I don't have as much time to play
you know there's plenty of dads out
there it's like hey I got a drop drop it
at any second so raids are tougher I
mean they Bad's a dozen you're awesome
about that they're really cool yeah just
cuz I always heard it's like hey you
scream the baby a bit all right take a
break everybody know it's like and
that's some of the communities you heard
about that came out of this is like
because you still have that son of you
wanted to play this type of stuff right
and the raids are some of the coolest
experiences in the game now for a solo
player it's tough now if a solo player
is like hey if they work up and they
solo the nightfall and they get one
powerful Engram a week that's towards
that tier you say like the say if you do
the heroic strikes you might get like a
zero to two improvement one maybe the
night falls like five and you can slowly
work on grain and there if you're doing
that something along those lines first
solo person it's I mean it's Fitness is
you got this Walt's gonna say but you
got to step out of your box a little go
so what lfts for I know it's not in the
game but lft net well it is in the game
would still work good okay fair enough
lfg I'll say that from but in general
that experience of the raid is what
destiny has at it's like it's its
capstone that it is its final piece of
content that is putting everything
you've done in the game together and
that's one of the things they want more
people to experience exactly getting
more incentive to finally venture out
into that one guys what's a veil Jerry
you need incentive to get in there you
need incentive for people to step out of
their box and wrecks and that's what I
was like I must solo player a lot you
guys know I do solo nightfalls that's
fine and I enjoy the challenge but in
turn if you want a good challenge but
part of its being social and it depends
on the situation but right and I'm
hoping with this maybe will pull some
people back there's some cool raid you
know Sherpas and things out there if you
need a team absolutely
but as more and more content and things
like that come back mm-hmm
and hopefully when it comes to September
a big push of people back in all these
incentives they're putting in this will
keep people playing longer so absolutely
I completely agree I think you know that
I think like you said they have to
incentivize their best content and you
also that made a great point which is
you know we got a step out the box I
remember like I wouldn't do trials I'm
gonna begin I wouldn't touch trials I
was just like I mean like when early
destiny like you know yeah I was just
too intimidated but I'm like now and at
that point I really didn't wasn't that
good it wasn't really a crucible player
oh I hated the crucible when I first had
destiny and then hazard got when I got
my feet wet my boundaries and then I got
through meeting the war quest and I
started getting my druthers
and then finally I'm like all right you
know grabbed up two guys or you know
clan mates or what have you and lfg you
know shot the xbox one they've got a
built-in lfg system in the UI yep you
know you don't even have to go today
like it's literally any lines very very
good and boom there I was you know
playing trials getting gigai my doctrine
of passing oh man so long dude I got you
to pass it it changed my life
like I felt like auto-rifle I would it
just took off so it's like again these
are the type of experiences that I had
to jump out of my comfort zone right do
something I necessarily wasn't good at
nor did I really want to do at the time
play and play with other people and then
I reward and I'm like man trials is
really fun and I you know I kind of got
into it
same thing with the race you know I mean
I would avoid shout the law you know
more king is in check you know I would
avoid it wouldn't do it like any like
look man we're gonna do crota you just
stay over the quarter a gala hall we
tell you that's how you learn you know
it's just listen we've got to get out of
this then again this is no disrespect to
anybody but you know gotta get out of
this me too
culture with destiny they're slowing
content that is difficult and that's
what makes you better
that's what makes my trying I mean like
we're and everybody's from a different
generation I mean you probably have
every age range sitting in here just
even listening to have much less
watching our videos later mm-hm
depending on what you grew up doing
games like Mega Man two or three they
kicked you're absolutely right exactly
that's what I grew up on it's like you
had a short level like I go back and I
play it now and you have the same state
so it's like okay before this hard
jumping shank section I can save and if
I die I load it right back here you can
blow through the game a lot quicker that
way cuz it doesn't have the like risk
like not to learn your jumps learn feel
like okay this platform appears here
here wait jump okay doc like you learn
and you learn and it's it's just like so
many things it takes time to learn and
that's why I think it's good they have
raid and trials not everybody likes both
sides of it if you don't like crucible
and trials in your thing parade every
activity of PD and it's possible if your
crucible and you're not so much on the
PvE trials be that elite beast who's
gonna shoot me without even me knowing I
saw you in the first place shake my head
off that trout like it's for both sides
so whatever your skills you can hit that
elite if you're good at both than a
you'll just get a little quicker but
mm-hmm
I agree completely agree man completely
so this was huge I mean yeah oh I was so
excited to see this because it's just it
gives us incentive again forever 29 was
painful but I can tell you I did that
raid every week on every damn character
until I got it and that I haven't had
the incentive to do that so something
like that comes back you're not late in
that go for it you're on a roll go for
it this is setting up September with
something yeah I did not see that coming
I don't want to get gay like me and you
I can we think the same so it's like I
know where you go it and when I saw this
I know people like to you guys are
overreacting yeah but these are the type
of changes that I never thought they
would do right now these are the type of
changes that when you add a bunch of
these kind
Changez then a dlc then now come
September you know it's like if you you
can theoretically put it all together
like you could make this thing come back
again I don't want to get too ahead of
myself but this is what I'm talking
about man like I was just like wow okay
we get it we get it and we think about
this this is actually before the summit
right this is something that thought
would come as a result of the summit
yeah people hearing that and this is
they they beat them to it so everybody's
like okay power okay we still want power
but you guys are on board with us so
next it's like okay so it's I did not
expect it and I'd love to see and so for
some details for you guys we'll try and
read through some of the high points
planning Grahams are gonna offer necks
like reward while people climb to the
soft cap so if your level up a new
character jumping in its gonna help you
kind of get closer to your team they
should grant Ward's of an average of 15
power level higher than your current on
your way up to the stop gap once you're
at the soft cat zero to two yep
so they're not just gonna be throwing
gear at you anymore your tattoos not a
big boost especially as you have five
slots to fill exactly so then they say
an effort to combat exploits which most
people they save up the exotic engrams
they save up tokens all that stuff it's
not gonna be that way you can't just
like turn in a bunch of stuff and I'm
like thank you thank you I hate that oh
and being honest like no disrespect to
any streamer
I couldn't stand when a new DLC comes
out and and everyone's just farming out
likes hoarding these these engrams to me
like yeah like cash in as soon as the
DLC drops and now they're MaxLite or
close to back yeah I'm actually in four
hours I was like ah yeah like please I'm
so glad like that's a huge deal again
actually kind of overlook this one
gradual repeated this because yeah like
that's that's dope like put let's get
back to doing the work let's get back to
that mmm like seriously put the work in
put the effort in there so so basically
what it means is there's also things
like the one time quest rewards we
three characters okay so some people
might save a character or me I haven't
finished them on every character on
every console just cuz I don't need
duplicates I don't need my third minute
multi-tool but then later on if you're
like hey we're gonna do this and I'm in
a multi-tool for so-and-so
well now it's only gonna drop at 260 so
I can't just save up that exotic go do
it and warm mine and have it be my next
quest so some people might even been
like hey I've got the gear and a vault
space may be a nightmare we'll see how
that's get fixed we'll just delete it
run back through again let me get a mini
multiple there's for guaranteed exotic
so loosen me up not an option anymore
like you truly have to do the new stuff
yes stop it's not being bad played a
game stop exploiting cheesing hoarding
engrams play the game that I I'm
actually surprised this took so long
because you would think even in when
destiny was in its hey they were kind of
frown upon that you know I mean like so
I'm glad that that's something that's
long overdue this this is really
underrated yeah we've got so if the
quest is with destiny one vanilla it
kept the eggs reward caps at about 260
and if use it's a level up it might be
fifteen parallels higher curse of Osiris
exotic and I'm trying to think what that
would even be or maybe stuff when you
when you level up on I guess yeah when
it's you know he still has the option to
drop forged weapons provided you to
acquire them so and I guess I'm when a
date they had a chance to trap well at
highlight or with a master work to be
master works as well yes that's what
they mentioned I guess quest rewards
they're not specific exotics so that's
very good
and then war mind we'll see what they've
got for quest so hopefully more a lot
more like all the things possible to do
and those cap at 3:40 again that's the
south cap formats you can't just go do
the weapon quest you can get the weapon
right that's not gonna help you level up
right again a see in its the content
it's either the nightfall the prestige
might follow the milestones those are
the things and once you're out for a
week
that's as high as you're getting you
can't farming exotics to increase your
power has been removed so grinding those
public events open for exotics if it's
not from a weekly source as in powerful
gear the Engram will drop at the same
power level as a legendary wood god
that's a soft cap so you can grind for
all the exotics you want mm-hmm they're
gonna be 340 good you love it all so
they believe the changes questionable
words and exotic farming will ensure the
most effective way to reach power kappas
play the most challenging and social
weekly activities BAM dude I'm in heaven
right now I'm just like smiling from ear
to ear I'm just like this is what I'm
talking about so would heard the Bungie
destiny gods have listened to my call
I'm talking about it so exciting yeah I
mean I can't wait to see for one people
are still gonna try and break it so
hopefully they like hopefully there
isn't too bad of an exploit anywhere I
really want to be like hey would you get
on your first week oh I got to about
three depends on when they drop the rate
of course do trials maybe I'll be like
355 if I'm lucky I'm like okay like and
you're going to 385 to go that's weeks I
mean that's at least I can play gotta
play and it just was so satisfying I
remember whenever they would be a big
content truck and everybody's like look
man you cuz my whole clan would be on
and we just be grinding cuz just like
look man have raids coming I gotta be
max like you know their before or after
we see you know whatever whatever that
you leave was about a week or maybe just
a couple of days right before let's say
there the content dropped in the
Tuesdays I'm telling like the raid went
live on a Friday and it's just like yo
don't 348 you got to go hard or the net
until the next week you gotta go hard I
missed that and I it really gave value
to that number that number meant
something I remember when you you know
somebody else came in you like dude you
got a hard work to get up there
I'm gonna go to the new raid lair at 270
you'll be fine oh I'm not ready he's
like you know just just come I'm like
really I was nowhere near level for the
REA lair we only only attempted it once
we already got we got to the posing for
a shot but I was like this no it's like
I'm literally hanging and doing my thing
able to hang with this high-end content
no yeah shout out to chat guys thank you
for tuning in this morning but yeah I
mean a lot of you guys are saying the
same thing and so on the solo it's like
and it's just gonna take longer but if
you're a solo player again for me the
same way
do you have instance have to login to do
anything right now not really I do it
for content for videos and then it's
just a challenge for that type of thing
but really if you're kind of at that max
level this is your time to take a break
now is your time that hey if you want to
put some work in grind through be like
it's gonna take you you want to try and
knock as much out as possible every week
just have to do more stuff so and to the
people to the country to the people who
are concerned about this you know again
I challenge you what is the alternative
right the alternative is what we have
now where you can get all this powerful
gear from all these different sources
without even stepping foot in high-end
activities and guess what if you're
really honest with yourself and you've
got every exotic and you've got max
level and you've done it in a week why
would you come back to play destiny you
have everything there's no incentive
there's no incentive to even do the race
and this is a person who myself who
likes to race like if horn is giving me
gray gear and frayed weapons at
highlight and public events and giving
me all these exotics at highlight and
I'm maxing out without even stepping
flip it just do it's just not right
ya know it's like if you work on
collecting and then just um no offense
less exotics
mm-hm less exotics dropping I
works every other milestone is an exotic
yes exactly
keep it to that yeah keep it to the
higher end stuff well I mean again they
gotta have some exact to drop somewhere
I get it but just we just gotta tone it
back we just gotta reel it in just a
little you know I mean and make it where
remember when you had to do remember the
days when und d1 you had to do the ninth
floor for a chance at in exotic
the night fall was your chance and then
the raid final in the right chest and
then the final encounter yeah like three
chances a week for an exotic it was hard
not every other public event or every
powerful it seems to throw me one
oh my god like I only I don't even do
that many powerful year milestones and I
saw I get one to two exotics a week now
granted they're the same couple that I
have I've seen 14 of them but that's
fine bread still like quit throwing them
at me make them matter more and this is
that I'm probably a bigger change for
fall yeah I think I think suddenly that
maybe low-key and play for me I think
subtly by them even mentioning it in
this update by stating that you know the
they trying to farm exotic sources and
stuff like that I think I think it's
gonna be this might is my theory I think
it's gonna be remember how like three
accounts like low-key stealth nerf no I
think we're gonna get a stealth nerf as
far as exotics in public events they
recognize it they're saying it right
they're saying people are farming and
we're gonna put a stop that they're
saying we know you guys hold on the
engrams whenever there's a new DLC
they're saying this stuff so for them to
say they were where I would not be
surprised cause to be honest I low-key
love the three coins is basically
useless ready
there's no they throw at me so much I
don't feel like I need to buy it anyway
exactly so the fact that it's gone
doesn't seem to matter but now three
coins is one of those that it took
something out of d1 yeah it was it was
nice cuz you're like hey you've trying
to grind for it you'll pop like 15 you
know you might get that extra one it was
like it was kind of just the time sink
for coins but they do
like there needs to head back to the
nine and then you do a rebuild and
figure out like a new system because sir
alone needs some help too
now I don't know if he wore mine
probably not but for fall he's got to
get a fix because what do you want from
him which were looser well I mean what
happened even just like the sparrow
tails or the ornaments or the weapon
bundles I look back at one of my old
videos you had the weapon and the
ornament you'd buy them together cost
you a little bit of dust cost a little
bit of shards just I don't I don't know
if it's going back to that but what it
is right now he's so late here's there's
three pieces of armor and a weapon by
it's just so robotic and almost useless
it's like I've been collecting my hunter
stuff just cuz I haven't built a hunter
on PC he's going to before this thing
comes out so I get my power cap up there
hmm I don't know there's one of those
that's felt like really empty since d2
lunched it was another one of those
things that felt like it was a rush to
be like alright we gotta throw them in
there throw a few exotics in his
inventory that's it I mean you're making
a good point you make it a good point um
I'm also curious if I should just
totally throw him out the window and be
like yeah he's out of town for like a
year and then hiatus he's taken
sabbatical like I don't know what if he
came back once a month that I wouldn't
be I wouldn't be upset but the way the
way I look at it is let's just be real
he bothers sir is not for us no is for
the new player right the new destiny
player the casual player that doesn't
have the time or had just been for
whatever reason in conjunction with not
having the time being extremely unlucky
on getting exotics so he serves his
purpose in that sense like for a new
player to destiny I get it you get
excited when this guy comes around right
you don't play a lot I get it for us
they have to incentivize him there's
still no reason for an hardcore guy to
be going reserve every week like this
really nice so they have to figure out a
balance in that respect you know you
know that's true I mean yeah it would be
nice but again I don't yeah I don't know
if it's one of those things that we can
actually
fix quickly cuz that's like a full
rework but yeah he understand he's not
for you guys for everybody I think it's
one of those things if they're gonna do
something it may be like but you know
for the September update with him I
agree with you though
they have to do something with it he's
just stagnant it's really you know they
got to figure something out some
practical functional use where he has
value to both the casual player and the
hardcore player like is there anything
I'm asked you a question like is there
anything you were thinking about that
they could do with him that you had in
mind that you wanted maybe to add see I
mean it's like happen I could probably
think on some random stuff Coronas
headed ease it's like what if Kurt sir
came once a week but it was only one
exotic and it was totally random
mmm-hmm well what would it this way what
did you feel about um I mean I thought
it was an honest attempt but okay it's
him what did you what would you have
opinion of faded Engram or you were like
completely against it I don't mind it
per se I mean it does take some of the
orangie out and if you're gonna spend a
hundred shards it's kind of it's okay to
know that we get something new but don't
have it up there as it often because
then people in start ok checklist are
great new one new one he knew I knew I
knew a new one and you just like
crossing them off your list without just
with other stuff the shards are there
spend it it's there I mean is it easy to
come by I mean if you're like burnin
through them once a week you probably
might whittling down the ward set it to
and I heard this I can't remember
probably multiple places between
fireteam and Guardian radio exertion
have an exotic quest ok now you talking
nah
now you talking old-school exotic bounty
kind of stuff yeah remember I believe I
don't what call me if I'm wrong wasn't
is it one of the one of the old exotic
bounty quest is you have to wait for her
to come around again yeah like they
gotta come up with creative stuff like
that so that you know you need him as
part of a quest line you don't mean for
certain exotics and stuff like that now
that's dope I'm with you on it I like
that a lot back job so having
come back on Friday or whatever then
he's here now he's here longer in d2
than he is in d1 he was here like Friday
to Sunday so a short-lived I guess
they're giving people more time but if
he was like you know once a week and say
he's got to leave for a reset so you
give him something or you got a grind
through you got to do ten strikes and
you know collect this random drop of
four different things that drop take it
back dessert he goes back does this
thing brings it back the next week maybe
it's a multi-week quest I mean give us
something's gonna take a little while to
finish not like I can go burn through a
question for a minimal tea tool in a fat
microRNA and have an exotic like make me
work for it completely come and get him
off the map yeah why is he vini why does
he have a beat you know the man why does
he have like a GPS looking around
children some like so smile I gave him a
hug yeah kid he's got a little blinky
beacon honestly he got just once many
tentacles in his face he can't see
everything he saw it you know you got to
get them while you can
so we finally fundable down in the tower
and were like hard stay out of our tower
your tentacles are freaking us out
they're hiding or planets and just hide
in the caves a tree of high in a tree
he's in a dark room he's in a dark cave
or he for so tighten and etz he's again
up in a tree so he's on top of that like
utility box or whatever's up there like
like put him I don't know what if he's
just sitting there like why can't he
just all of a sudden stand next to ash
for me or an ashram has some weird
commentary be like dude this dude is
freaking me out
beast love is character we get they got
if they got to figure him out man I mean
like I said I'm not super mad with fader
feeding Ingram on some level but again
there's a lot of people who hoard shards
so they can literally within the first
three to four weeks keep checking in and
getting every excited
off the list you know and uh yes my
stuff got out to a ward he said he's be
he logged into Facebook so he's on the
grid now we've got him tracked I'm
finally logged into Facebook and they've
got himself face yeah I mean like there
would be another one again you guys know
flashpoints turned into long points but
again this was a tangent I didn't even
expect again I'm Buzzard needs some work
like he's another one you think of
exotics like he's the one who throws him
at you it's like I don't even have a
hunter and I just go by one a week and
just you know build my collection
without a lot of effort yeah you're
right that's absolutely right I mean
it'd be one of those weeks where it's
like hey so sir logs in and he's got
he's got an energy weapon in Graham but
you buy one of them crap mostly yeah two
times it would be broken and it would be
current yes
see I don't people would buy the living
crap out of that like we yeah we used to
have the engrams right remember back any
day you would have either a foot Engram
or a helmet in grant and they could do
it like that like you said an energy
weapon with their all I think it was a
rabbit's foot for some reason to say
okay I remember this is like early d1
and I was like oh my like obsessed with
trying to get obsidian mine and he would
have you know the helmet in gram it be
for a high price but it wasn't
guaranteed I was getting that upset
could be any warlock helmet right and
that that's what I like that that's
better because if you do this guaranteed
R and G for something you don't have
you're gonna burn through this thing
again quick yeah like and this is this
is the stuff for fall that this I think
for I feel like look summit is gonna
cover a lot of stuff yes most of the
ideas out there I don't know how much
talk has been thought about sir and this
the other bigger things right now he's
probably going to dock it I'm gonna go
ahead and package this in and like put
it in a FedEx box and overnight it up to
the summit for my little feedback as
well that's a lot this man this is what
the other people don't think of like
this sure ain't getting no love right
now it's a good point it's enough I'm
gonna put it this way we would first
talk about that power now I'm putting it
out there I'll take credit we got to put
our chests and they doing it but yeah
absolutely absolutely sir needs to be on
the list
yeah so many cool ideas that's like
you've got I mean the engrams I think
would be cool it's just one in Graham
you know what type it is okay helmet I
want to get on my warlock because I know
it's their quests from him like exotic
bounties that involved him I said Saudis
they better have some exotic ones in
there like yeah right I'll be a perfect
segue remember that thorn grind when it
was the original
remember to chaperone one oh that was I
think that might be the one I'm thinking
of that was brutal
yeah I'm finally done even a but it was
like and then don't make the exotic sock
but exactly it's gotta be gotta be worth
a grind and I think that comes back to
making the in-game stuff matter to if I
run a raid do not give me a taken King
Kings fall garbage auto rifle or hand
cannon as a reward or I'm gonna pop like
that's the type of stuff like they've
done decent so far like midnight coup
some of these things to really kind of
them are trash
but don't get don't make one of the
worst couple of guns from the raid right
that was you you have to tweak those to
be powerful that just that's the whole
nature of a year those guns have to have
a level a small level of o-p-s because
you need to incentivize people to do it
if that one extra perk slot give them a
little bit faster way a little bit more
stability
than that wants something of that
category little more impact something so
if you have that you're like this is
again more incentive to run that in game
you got to give us a reason and they're
working on the reasons but it's
absolutely you got to get there and
weapons lots of randomization saw there
but you got to make those I want those
raid I want the trials weapons I want a
reason to go run trials mm-hmm
absolutely all of that stuff excuse me
got the hiccups right now it's always
fun oh but yeah like so much good stuff
but yeah they just did say right now the
12 the weekly blog address whatever you
want to call it people have an issue
with the 12 but that's fine each has an
issue with the Kullen tois bungees
bungees blog whatever you'd like to call
it everybody's in town so being a fly on
the wall in the room shout-out to those
guys making some work and doing some
future changes division did this mm-hmm
division has made a large turnaround now
has it been quick no but these are
things for you know taking Queen or
whatever's in the fall this could be for
your next expansion after that this
could be for your May 20 19 these are
big changes that are gonna be rolling in
the future or so hopefully some some big
game things happen the ironed some cool
stuff out we get some fun stuff and good
things coming absolutely ma'am
absolutely good stuff yeah that pretty
much wraps it you guys know the details
on on banner power animals coming back
quicker which is nice I like how that's
dropping as you said and then you got a
couple of things of the week so that
that's pretty much it so April 24th guys
it is Tuesday
I work at 1:30 I work at it's noon and I
work at 1:30 I'm literally gonna be like
chomping at the bit here I'm not gonna
weekly reset video anything done till I
get back from work so what time you
think they do the stream for the UH the
2024 off oh they're saying 10:00 a.m.
Pacific oltenia all right cool I'm going
to be hurtin but I'm gonna stay well you
need to get like a nap
then get back up like one watch the
stream pass out yeah yeah soon as I get
it
Mayibuye yeah you need to have like you
know a piece of egg and toast and two
benadryl pass big good yeah and then set
like four alarms pop up mm-hmm
do your stuff look over it man I'm gonna
go to work and just be like oh let me
focus on work wrong then come back home
and work on some some thought I actually
like this there was one of the guys in
the nightfall top scores for the tree
abroad the probabilities his name is
literally just grilled chicken stop
it's just ch i ke and but still mm-hmm
everybody else has got their crazy but
yeah shout out to grilled chicken nice
to have to go check it out the esoteric
just uh Chris just said on my chat and
he just uploaded another max handicap
knifing he said I did actually wants
that one he said like there was a lot of
cheese involved some hiding stuff like
that it's like I finished it yeah
esoteric dude beast I was like I do my
solo night falls in a very different way
commentary some just like explanations
of what's going on he's just showing
pure skill be due to madman either bees
dreams
absolutely but guys yeah Tuesday is
gonna be big I don't believe it's good
they already like you saying it it's
really hitting like yeah oh yeah awesome
stuff coming and we'll see a stream will
see some campaign stuff honestly I'm
hoping there's one thing that nobody's
seen yet one little tidbit one little
like you know piece of text that pops up
that like everybody goes like it's like
they need a couple any like a like you
said some moments like that they need a
secret they need like a black spin no
kind of thing to something in that war
money need like something like that
and again I'm kind of keep expectations
good but if they could just do something
with that damn really yeah I don't know
how they're gonna do that to me it's
gonna feel so disconnected why don't
worry
all right it's the last part of the rail
a this should conclude the Leviathan
have the war minds some war holds the
blow - I've heard worse
let's double cross this triple cross
Calais you know let's do some you know
get that they got it it's like I don't
know if there's anything in our the
thing eats planets I don't know if
there's anything in our entire solar
system that's remotely close enough to
even put a dent in it I feel like
honestly he's just sitting with us but I
feel like he could literally just
swallow up our solar system and keep
driving it's literally like a drive-by
be like by solar system
dude the hungry hungry hippo yeah galaxy
ders I hope they do something that's my
whole I know it's a long shot
oh man that we need Walmart to be good
man we really do yeah and even if it is
apartment to be but you got like the
penthouse apartment you got a little
more room you got a few more places yo
you got a couple more bosses like maybe
they I think the one multiple bosses
then multiple bosses flexible bosses
first time Indy to multiple I'm sorry
wait what multiple encounters because
you go war priest this is a full
encounter to learn you have a stuff in
between
then you've got like and I don't know if
they were trying to get away from that
for some reason but at least give me two
little encounters to learn cool stuff in
between each one that's cool that'd be
even better than just one so well yeah
for them tying it into the story I have
no earthly idea how they're gonna do
that and unfortunately I'm not sure they
will somehow it was like okay this was a
vex related tree of probabilities
somehow there's vex in the dumpster of
oh I know I mean that was like that was
as far as you can stretch that yeah
listen as long or if they ever again as
long as they strive to somehow connect
it and just okay if it's not connected
can we just please have a dope
conclusion to calais story wise this
whole Cal
thing obviously this is the trilogy of
the raid lair wrap it up let's put a
nice spin cuz I will say this as much as
you know I hated part two I don't like
either were either worlds is the worst I
don't even classify I was doing rankings
someone in the house like like I have
crota above either layer because I like
kurta more than most people give it
credit for me yeah because I thought it
fit the theme yes for a theme it was and
there it was crazy like beast and that's
it like that first encounter BMS is the
epitome of what that raid was supposed
to be and I learned it that's what I'm
talking about she lost a fireteam you
had this sense of you know we gotta get
in like it was it listen for all of the
move exactly exactly so for all his
fault it you know it did serve the
aesthetic and they serves the storyline
purpose of what they were trying to
accomplish which is Leviathan I did like
the end when okay we realize okay you
know spoilers to boss careless any boss
careless okay you know saying you know
here it is but um no and I thought okay
we're gonna really go off on that whole
tangent more and you know getting him
gonna basically either world just
getting us to clean his apartment I got
this thing in my by par me and you're
the Xterra me to get rid of it now no no
max mines getting a little too friendly
with the trash she's changing time
around he's trying to go or and they're
just go shoot him will you thanks
mmm-hmm so it's like let's just put a
nice little bow in this thing let's get
some clarity on catalyst let's end it up
nicely let's put a whole little
cinematic if we can and just be done
with it and then you know please
it was nice nice thought I mean it was
toss up because we had crota which was a
bigger one and I think they had more
time to develop that on the other flip
side curse of us I just got really
really
so they had the rate in there but then
when we came later on we got trials so
people kind of forget you had another
mode though yeah
oh if like somehow they did this is the
one thing I'm wondering if they're gonna
do if there is war mine and there's
another there's a horde mode there's a
challenge of elders there's anything
like that on top of everything else
we're getting that might set this one up
to be like okay cool mm-hmm yep yeah so
mmm
I think that'll wrap it that'll be wrap
that we did a flask away unbelievable
it's probably one of our shorter ones
last week's have been insane so we're
gonna be long oh yeah it one I don't
know we'll probably be back to Friday
next week I'm gonna be seeing Avengers
at 11:30 my tools so we can still
probably knock it out before we go
it's IMAX has got a reserved seat so I
could walk in five minutes before and
still be good I love that shut up
Avengers infinity war I'm probably gonna
put some dollars into the box office
there because I'm gonna see that
multiple times
oh but yeah it's like Tuesday's gonna be
a lot we'll wait for the weekly update
which probably won't add a lot more
because the trailer is gonna be
everything in that stream and yeah
Friday we will have some stuff to talk
about so if you guys are out there tune
back in this is our usual consistent
time a day sometimes moves if things hit
the fan I doubt we'll do one Tuesday
afterwards just cuz that's a little
early in the week so we'll line it up
for Friday next week and other than that
guys I will be working this afternoon
but I will try and do definitely some
solo night falls Friday night I don't
have much else to do and yeah always
tune in here on Twitch on YouTube for
both of us shout out iron Lords podcast
inner circle Network go check him out
guys there's we got a big one you Sunday
come check us out on the inner circle
Network we will have Windows Central's
old jazz cordon so I'm looking forward
to that he's a big guy out here in the
community so I was gonna be good to ask
him some questions and the state of
things and he's a he's a good follow on
Twitter so all yeah we're gonna have him
on it's gonna be fun
and yeah that's gonna like I said you
know at Laura Cognito on Twitter all
that good stuff and Xbox and uh actually
Xbox 360 and Nami SUV extra ps4 is about
tag is a kognito 360 excuse me check is
that we got some we got some stuff going
on in cooking and we will be back at our
normal time for flashpoint hopefully on
Friday and this was a nice little
special edition for you guys so enjoy it
with my panty boxes always guys so same
thing here twitch.tv slash abundance if
you guys are watching live thank you if
you haven't followed hit that little
follow button always appreciated also on
Twitter follow us both always could come
terry jokes random news happenings going
on and then right there on YouTube for
both of us hit those subscribe buttons
and hit that little alert bill it really
helps us out likes comments all the
goodies you guys made it this far in the
video I can dump all this stuff on you
guys so all the support we do this for
you guys just because we have fun
talking about it and the support every
time makes a difference you guys don't
honestly know like I read every comment
all the stuff you guys see in chat same
with you guys over there it's like just
any interaction we have with you guys is
great never thought I'd be able to do
anything like this
and have any bit of a notion of people
to talk to so you met another crazy
yesterday feel like you said our
business cards like crazy people
but also just the fact that we're like
do it podcast over destiny now and just
you guys are commenting on like all the
stuff soy sauce Mon show everybody and
everything shout to fill the thrilling
in chat today on my side as well Chris
covertly one of our loyal ones I saw Jay
Fonzarelli Lord addict is in the
building Lord King was in it earlier
thank you guys again like I said much
appreciated for showing the love to our
little passion project and we will keep
this thing going man and if we if we're
proven right it would be the greatest
turnaround and SP the dark people were
laughing at us we even doing this now
like I don't know apparently were
gluttons for punishment not sure loved
the game too much [ __ ] shout out to
gaming addict he said he's gonna play
the DLC even in apart
Toodee mom here we go alright yeah so
for everybody around the world cuz I
don't know where you guys are sitting at
but somewhere on the globe good
afternoon could be good morning good to
be good evening
enjoy your guys day and have a good one
peace